for over a hundred years National
Geographic explorers have unraveled the
mysteries of the past now it's your turn
to participate in an ongoing National
Geographic expedition hi I'm Albert Lin
I'm a UCSD research scientist and a
National Geographic emerging Explorer
Albert and his team are surveying
important archaeological sites in
Mongolia's Valley of the Khans the
relatively unexplored homeland of
jenga's Khan
they have collected thousands of GOI
satellite images of the region it's your
job to explore the landscape and tell
them what you see
you'll be tagging the items such as
rivers roads and most importantly
evidence of large buried objects you may
also see in Europe you should tag it as
a modern structure other examples of
what we'd like you to look for are like
this Bronze Age burial mound it looks
quite different from structures that
surround it this is what you should tag
as an ancient structure my team will be
exploring the objects you have tagged
real-time on the ground in Mongolia
once you've helped point them in the
right direction Albert and his team
including top Mongolian scholars will
target the most promising sites and
they'll do it without turning over a
single stone it's a revolutionary
non-invasive approach to archaeology
that uses some high-tech tools 3d
virtual reality ground-penetrating radar
and unmanned aerial vehicles the goal of
the valley of the Khans project is to
identify archaeological sites without
disturbing them promoting conservation
and awareness in this region of rich
cultural heritage
if we can do this if we can map a
cultural significance of this landscape
in time then we may be able to protect
it and protect this way of life before
it's too late
join our search today